c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli ajouté gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
et
mais vous êtes fous oh oui
à noter seulement c'est impensable
si mes deux parties au voilà elle est
vivant mais pas d'or c'est un
dégueulasse vous savez daniel ses basses
oeuvres c'est ma grand-mère en même
temps que le tout si c'est faux pas dit
cela c'est pour conjurer le mauvais sort
je regarde accord la semaine prochaine
il est très près la bbc une fois que je
ne cacherai pas qui évidemment la
proposition m'a été faite j'en ai été
très flatté mais je peux pas tout je
vois reprendre le talk show d'oprah
winfrey
ellen degeneres a commencé un petit peu
influent cheville et aussi aux states à
je pourrais pas être ou sur tous les
dossiers donc pour tpm [ __ ] zénith pour la
présentation sera pas pousser
mais chroniqueuse de temps en temps
[Musique]
dans mon état normal et des codes de
commune compte à ma récupère a réussi la
réserve était sous la menace est
vraiment mes cheveux nous fait chier tu
m as de style ici c'est votre problème à
la l1 du sopi 4
[Musique]